Finding the One Piece is the final step to
become king of the pirates. And with Luffy,
Blackbeard, and Shanks all
chasing the legendary treasure,
they are guaranteed to eventually clash
before the end of the story. But then
wouldn’t it make a ton of sense if the three
strongest pirate captains had one final epic
clash 1 vs 1 vs 1 to determine once and for
all who will become king of the pirates.
Which leaves us with a massively
interesting question: What would
happen if Luffy fought Blackbeard
and Shanks for the One Piece.
In this scenario, Luffy and the Straw Hats have
already collected all four Road Poneglyphs. They
have just landed on Lodestar island, the
final island in the Grand Line. And you
may be wondering why they are here, since
technically Lodestar is optional for the
Straw Hats. After all, this is the island that a
pirate should first learn about the poneglyphs,
which are these unbreakable stones that
have information from the Void Century.
And although the Straw Hats do not need
to learn about the poneglyphs, Roadstar
island is bound to hold other secrets about the
Void Century and the secrets of the One Piece.
And you might have noticed I have already
called this legendary island both Lodestar
AND Roadstar. And that’s because we don’t
actually know it’s real name. In Japanese
it is called ロードスター and of course in Japanese
there is no difference between R and L. So just
like for the longest time with Laugh Tale,
there is some confusion about the name. But
both names kinda make sense since a Lode stone
is basically a magnet which attracts metal. And
Roadstar works because you could have different
paths pointing out from the island like a star.
So they’ve landed on this mysterious island,
and even though we don’t actually know what
it looks like, I like to imagine it looks
something like this. And boy is Robin in
archeologist heaven as she uncovers the
ancient ruins that dot the island. And at
the center of it all is this magnificent temple
that explains the true nature of the Poneglyphs.
But while Luffy is bouncing around exploring,
an ear-splitting shriek rips through the
air. On the beach by the Sunny, Nami was
busy charting the course to Laugh Tale,
but now a creeping darkness is eating up the sand.
Nami and Zoro frantically run from the darkness,
until Zoro suddenly spins around in the blink
of an eye and blocks an invisible attack with
his swords. And the sheer force of the clash sends
Nami stumbling right into the creeping darkness.
She screams out for help, her voice cracking with
terror, as she is sucked into the black abyss.
And just as Nami is about to fully
disappear into the pitch black darkness,
Luffy swoops in at the last moment and
yanks her to the safety of higher ground.
Zoro leaps up to join the rest of the crew up
on the cliff, and together they stare down at
Blackbeard and his titanic captains. Somehow
the evil Yonko has followed the Straw Hats,
which means it is finally time
for their ultimate confrontation.
And of course Blackbeard can’t help himself,
so he dives into a dramatic speech about the
power of dreams and how it is his destiny to find
the One Piece. However, if blackbeard thought the
straw hats would just cower in fear like everyone
else, he was gravely mistaken. And right in the
middle of his speech, he gets absolutely
crushed by a giant punch from Luffy. And a
furious Nami unleashes bolts of lightning while
Franky blasts the enemy crew with laser beams.
The Straw Hats are not messing around.
And of course, there are many different ways this
could go down. One option is that Luffy could
initially be defeated, as happens in most story
arcs. Or since this is one of THE FINAL BATTLES,
Luffy might finally defeat his hated rival on the
first try. And since this clash will undoubtedly
take place in the main story, I am sure that the
godly version that Oda creates will blow all of
our minds. But that doesn’t mean we can’t have fun
imagining how this epic battle could go. And if
you thought Marineford was tragic, just wait until
you see what happens at the end of this video.
But one thing that is certain is these two
crews have been set up to fight from the very
first time that we meet Blackbeard. Both crews
have the same basic roles such as Navigator,
Swordsman, Doctor, Helmsman, and so on.
Plus, Blackbeard is the main reason that
Luffy’s brother Ace was killed, so, trust me,
there is plenty of motivation for this fight.
So the crew leaps down onto the shore to protect
the Sunny and forces the Blackbeard pirates to
retreat. Van Auger, the sniper of Blackbeard’s
crew, uses his teleportation devil fruit to
take all of the crew deeper into the island and
away from the Straw Hat’s onslaught. The Straw
Hats immediately give chase, with only Jinbe
and Brook staying behind to protect the ship.
And this is when the fight breaks up
into specific match ups. And while we
don’t know for sure how these fights would
go, we can reasonably guess based on what
we know about the characters from the
story. Of course, the one match up that
is guaranteed is Luffy versus Blackbeard.
The ultimate clash of the darkness versus
the sun. And this fateful battle begins in
the heart of the ancient temple. Blackbeard
immediately pulls Luffy in with his darkness
gravity, but Luffy’s crazy speed, strength,
and insane haki prove too much for Blackbeard,
and Luffy deals a devastating first blow.
Elsewhere around the island, Zoro and the
swordsman Shiryu are carving a path through
the forest. Even though Shiryu can turn
invisible, Zoro’s observation haki allows
him to sense the former jailer’s attacks, and the
pair exchange devastating slashes. Up in the sky,
Nami and Chopper are flying on Nami’s pet cloud
Zeus as they fight the crazy Doc Q. And this
sickly doctor unleashes bursts of horrifying
illness over the entire island, but Chopper
uses his medical expertise to counteract the
plagues. On this side of the island, Franky is
engaged in an epic wrestling match with the Buff
fruit user, Jesus Burgess. That leaves Sanji and
Robin to team up against the shape-shifting
Caterina Devon, the liquor fruit user Doc Q,
and the island fruit user Avalo Pizarro. And
of course we have the godly duel of snipers,
with Usopp and Van Auger literally attempt
to snipe each other from across the island.
And at this point, you might be wondering
about the former admiral Aokiji, who joined
Blackbeard’s crew during the time skip. But
personally I don’t believe he will remain
with Blackbeard’s crew by the end of the story,
so for this video let’s assume he is no longer
part of the crew. Likewise, it is possible that
Blackbeard eventually gains a third devil fruit,
but for this video we will assume he only
has the darkness and the tremor fruit.
But as the epic battle continues, let’s
recap the goals of each crew. The straw
hats already have the Road Poneglyphs, and Nami
already knows where to go to find Laugh Tale,
so really there is no reason they
have to stay. But Luffy and the
others surely want revenge for all the pain
Blackbeard has caused them in the story,
so for now they are fighting for their pride
and to stop a rival from finding the One Piece.
But the Blackbeard pirates actually do
need the copies of the Road Poneglyphs.
So by taking out the Straw Hats,
they will have everything they
need to reach Laugh Tale and for
Blackbeard to become pirate king.
But back to the battle. Blackbeard is not going to
be king of anything because he is being pummeled
by Luffy. Combining the imaginative powers of
Gear 5 and his advanced haki, Luffy delivers
blow after blow to his rival. Now Luffy
charges up for one final massive punch,
but as his fist connects with Blackbeard’s
face, Luffy is shocked when he is pulled
into Blackbeard’s darkness. Blackbeard
grabs Luffy’s arm, and, because of the
special powers of the darkness fruit, Luffy
immediately loses his devil fruit powers.
Now Blackbeard has taken a lot of damage,
but he still spreads his gap-toothed grin
because he has Luffy trapped. Enraged, Luffy
throws his head back to slam into Blackbeard,
but before he lands the blow,
Blackbeard ABSOLUTELY CRUSHES
Luffy with an earthquake-infused punch
that literally shakes the entire island.
But Luffy doesn’t stay down for long. He rises
from a crater in the center of the temple,
bleeding, and his legs wobbling. Still, he keeps
his own defiant smile on his face. What else
could we expect in this battle of legendary
D clan? However, one of these captains will
certainly not be smiling at the end of
this video. Keep watching to find out who.
Now you might have noticed that we haven’t yet
mentioned some of the Blackbeard crew members. And
this guy is kind of hard to miss. San Juan Wolf,
the giant fruit user, is walking in the ocean
toward the Thousand Sunny. And as we showed in
a recent video comparing sizes in One Piece, San
Juan Wolf can make himself more than three times
the size of the Straw Hat’s ship. So together,
Brook and Jinbe begin an all out assault against
the enormous man. And although he is super sized,
he actually is weakened by the effects of
the sea so this fight is pretty even for now.
And back around the island, Nami and Chopper
have managed to defeat Doc Q. They waste no
time in going to assist Sanji and Robin, but,
just as they reach their crewmates, the island
literally explodes, sending boulders hurtling
through the air. Sanji and Robin are thrown into
the sky like ragdolls. Good thing both of them can
basically fly, but as they regain their balance,
a giant face appears from the ground. Pizarro has
used the ridiculous powers of his devil fruit to
merged with the island and is now launching
giant chunks of rock at the straw hat crew.
Zoro sees what is happening and rushes over to
help the crew. Sanji takes over fighting the
invisible swordsman, getting revenge for missing
out on his favorite devil fruit. And just like he
did in Dressrosa, Zoro begins slicing up parts of
the island to try to take out Pizarro’s main body.
Meanwhile, Franky simply cannot
match the raw strength of Burgess,
and is his pinned to the ground.
But back on the shore, ALL HELL has broken loose.
With the massive San Juan Wolf threatening to
crush the Sunny, Brook and Jinbe are going all
out to protect the ship. But this leaves the
Sunny unprotected, and now the unthinkable
occurs. Rising from the deck of the ship,
the angel winged Laffitte flies away with every
copy of the Road Poneglyphs. And that’s it. The
Blackbeard crew has accomplished their main goal
and now they just need to— *pauseomentarily*
In a flash of black and red, an air-splitting
slash slices through Laffitte’s wing. With his
severed wing flapping uselessly, he falls
towards the ground like a rock. And so
do the Poneglyph rubbings. Until… they are
caught by a one armed man in a badass cape.
Shanks has arrived.
And you won’t believe how the
arrival of the Red Hair Pirates will
change the outcome of this battle.
Without warning, the Red Hair
pirates burst into the fray,
demanding that you subscribe to the channel.
Shanks leaves the precious poneglyphs on his
ship and then leaps to the temple. Luffy
and Blackbeard sense his awesome power
approaching and it takes a combined effort
to block a wicked sword slash from Shanks.
And Luffy is utterly confused, but Shanks
isn’t messing around. He delivers a massive
punch to Blackbeard that sends the evil captain
flying across the temple. Amd then he nearly
cuts off Luffy’s leg. While Luffy dodges, he
falls to the ground with his head spinning.
And Shanks sieves the opportunity to snatch
the treasured straw hat from Luffy’s head.
Stunned, Luffy can do nothing
but watch as Shanks smiles,
and places the hat upon his own head. He looks
at Luffy and says, “I’ll be taking this back.”
And this causes Luffy to literally
lose his mind. This is his first time
seeing his former hero in over twelve
years. It should be a happy moment,
but instead Shanks attacks him again.
With confused anger, Luffy strikes back,
and their overwhelming conqueror’s haki
reduces the temple all around them into rubble.
And it is at this point that we have
to acknowledge that Shanks is deadly
serious about this fight. In the manga,
it was revealed that Shanks definitely
intends to find the One Piece, so while
we don’t know his true motivations,
he clearly intends to take the copies of
the Poneglyphs in order to reach Laugh Tale.
And we don’t know exactly how strong
Shanks and his crew are compared to
everyone else. But from the way they
have been portrayed in the story so far,
I personally think that they are
the strongest crew in the story.
And this becomes obvious right away.
Usopp’s father Yasopp instantly snipes
Van Auger, clipping his hat with
a bullet from across the island.
Lucky Roux, this bowling ball of a
man, smashes into Burgess and Franky,
sending the two crashing into the ruins.
And the others join in, attacking both the
Blackbeard and Straw Hat crews. In fact, just
like how the Straw Hats and Blackbeard’s crew are
set up with similar roles, Shanks’ crew basically
is the same. Hongo is the doctor. Bonk Punch and
Monster are the musicians. Building Snake is the
navigator, so there are a lot of possibilities
for match ups between the three crews. And
the combined power in this potenital fight is
the most insane thing we will see in the stor
And needing the regroup, the Straw Hats
decide to pull together. Remember they
don’t actually need the poneglyphs, since
Nami already knows where Laugh Tale is,
but they also don’t want Blackbeard of Shanks
to have them. So while the rest of the crew
pulls back towards the Sunny, Zoro and Sanji
attack the Red Hair ship, intending to take
back the poneglyph rubbings. But that is no easy
task. They are met by Shanks’ right hand man,
Ben Beckman, and Howling Gab, who manage
to keep the Straw Hats off of the ship.
And with the battle spilling onto the
beach, Pizarro appears to try to crush
the enemy crews with a giant sand fist,
but this turns all the attention onto him,
and every sword user in the Straw Hat and Red
Hair crew attack at once, absolutely destroying
the island man. Defeated, Pizarro falls
unconscious in a bloody heap on the beach.
Back to the captains, Shanks is finally
getting revenge for Blackbeard scaring his
face all those years ago. The Red Hair captain
is relentless with his legendary sword skills,
unleashing attacks with the full
force of the absolute strongest
haki in the series. Blackbeard is forced
to defend with his tremor coated fists,
but he is struggling. As is Luffy. While Luffy
can block Shanks’ blade with advanced Conqueror’s,
Shanks isn’t giving him any openings to attack
because his future sight is slightly superior.
But with Shanks and Luffy momentarily
distracted with each other, Blackbeard
decides that this is a battle he would rather
not fight. He calls for Van Auger and the sniper
teleports in and just as quickly teleports
his captain back to the beach. Luffy and
Shanks clash a bit more, but then they both
sense something dangerous from the shore.
Although San Juan Wolf is weakened by the
water, he is still incredibly massive. So
he spreads his arms, closes his eyes, and begins
a massive belly flop onto the ships. The Straw
Hats and Red Hair crew focus all of their
attacks on him, but they simply cannot stop
the massive figure from falling. But then,
right before the giant crushes the ships,
Shanks and Luffy appear. And with a
blistering haki-filled fist and sword slash,
they absolutely destroy the giant and
send him flying across the island.
That’s one obstacle down. And many more to go.
But before Luffy can confront Shanks, his former
mentor disappears again. And down on the beach,
Robin shouts at Luffy, recommending that they flee
the battle. Again, they don’t need to be here,
and the only thing they risk here is being
defeated. So despite his desire to fight,
Luffy makes the wise choice to signal
the retreat. But before Robin can move,
Shanks appears behind her, grabs her by
the hair and puts his blade to her throat.
Damn. This is not going to end well for someone.
And at this point it is important to remember that
Robin is the only one here who is confirmed to be
able to read the poneglyphs. Blackbeard
did capture Big Mom’s daughter, Pudding,
and she might be able to read them if
she awakened her third eye abilities,
but that is uncertain. So even
though Shanks has the Poneglyphs,
he would still need someone to read them.
Which explains why he would kidnap her.
Luffy screams in rage. If there is one
thing that drives Luffy to the edge,
it is his friends being hurt. We’ve
seen it in Arlong Park, Enies Lobby,
and especially Sabaody. So if they are in
danger, Luffy will do anything to take her back.
Now Sanji tries to stop Shanks, but the
Red Hair captain dashes away with Robin.
Luffy tries to follow Shanks and Robin, but is
stopped by Jesus Burgess. After a few moments,
Luffy tosses Burgess aside, and then finds
Shanks clashing with Blackbeard near the
waves. But Robin is nowhere in sight. As we can
all imagine, Luffy is furious. And so while he
may have been subconsciously holding back against
his former friend, he now unleashes his full fury
against Shanks. And Shanks is slightly distracted
by Blackbeard, so he senses Luffy’s attack late.
And this momentary slip has
devastating consequences.
Luffy pummels Shanks into the ground, spewing
sand and water into the air. Luffy unleashes
a storm of punches until Ben Beckman
attacks Luffy from the side. Luffy dodges,
but it allows Shanks to rise to his feet.
He is shaken from the attack. Blood drips
down his face. His eyes are unfocused. He
raises his sword. But then, he freezes.
Blood spurts from his mouth. He looks down.
Three blades stick out from his chest,
and then from behind Shanks, a sickening laugh
breaks the breathless silence of the beach.
Blackbeard withdraws his three knives,
standing over Shanks as he falls to the ground.
Luffy is stunned. Tears form
in his eyes. Conqueror’s haki
erupts in overwhelming bursts of rage and
sadness, shaking the island. His mentor,
his friend, is dying in front of him.
He cannot handle it. His eyes tremble.
But then another shriek rips across
the island. Near Blackbeard’s ship,
Robin is struggling against Shanks.
Wait, what? Hold on. Shanks is dying
on the ground. What is going on???
As the second Shanks locks Sea prism on Robin’s
wrist, his form changes. And the shape-shifting
Caterina Devon laughs as she holds up the
weakened Robin. The rest of the straw hats
rush to help Robin, but they are held back
by the Blackbeard crew. The Red Hair pirates
circle around to help Shanks, but Hongo simply
shakes his head. There is nothing he can do.
Shanks is dying.
And with his last ounce of strength, he points
at Luffy. The trembling Luffy steps forward,
barely able to move, and he falls
to his knees. The rage is gone,
and now only tears remain. Luffy says that is
sorry. Over and over again he repeats it through
his tears. But Shanks shakes his head and says
that if he cannot get to the One Piece himself,
then it is Luffy’s responsibility
to find it before Blackbeard does.
So with his dying breath, Shanks orders
his crew to stop Blackbeard and help Luffy
escape. Then he places the straw hat back on
Luffy’s head. And the light in his eyes fades.
While holding back tears, the Red Hair pirates
stand. No matter the sadness they feel,
they will follow their captain’s last command.
So they take the fight to the Blackbeard crew,
seeking vengeance for their fallen captain.
Luffy joins in, smashing everything while
crying out in his grief. Eventually,
they rescue Robin and the crew pulls back
But Luffy cannot control himself. He was tricked
and it cost Shanks his life. So he is desperate to
keep fighting, and it takes the combined efforts
of Zoro and Nami to bring him away from the fight.
So the Red Hair pirates hold off Blackbeard
and his crew. The Straw Hats, including the
badly injured Franky, have just enough time to
board the Sunny and escape into the stormy seas.
And next there is only one place to
go. Laugh Tale. But it will not be
simple for the Straw Hats to get there,
because Blackbeard would undoubtedly be
chasing him all the way. And on top of that the
marines will certainly redouble the efforts to
stop Luffy from finding the One Piece and
the ancient secrets of the void century.
And with the straw hats weak from this insane
battle, there may not be a better chance for the
marines to do just that. Can you imagine Akainu
swooping in and taking out the straw hats right
after Shanks died? And even MORE interesting
scenario could be what if the marines actually
managed to capture Luffy? What would the rest of
the crew do? And who would come to save him? Well,
if you’re curious to learn how that might
play out, you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching.